I don't have a process that I stick by
like a set rule book that I say right if
I'm creating a character I'm gonna do
this this this there's so many different
inputs that kind of then you just kind
of see what comes out the other end and
hopefully it's it's something that is
good about the boy when you're a kid
acting it's more kind of it's it's
playtime I mean it still is as an adult
but you're less kind of going into kind
of the technical things that you have in
your Raiders neck that's the kind of
disappearance or occurrence and luckily
with that I mean obviously the cast in
that movie Hugh Grant and Toni Collette
and Mitchell Vice and all these people
are amazing to work with so you kind of
acting is always that thing that you're
kind of on the same level of anyone else
you're doing the scenes with and also
the directors chris and paul weitz were
amazing and the writing so that kind of
made my job as it were as an 11 year old
pretty easy I mean I had son before not
not on film and not in front of I think
there's 600 people within their audience
that day and not with Hugh Grant
[Music]
who is daunting scary oh I remember all
that everyone was very supportive on the
day and encouraging and I mean exacting
so this kind of a way of differentiating
it if it was me going out there to try
and sing well that would be horrifying
but luckily it's meant to be the
character singing badness definitely
occasionally something that people be
like seen killing me softly for a while
take you out of the movie came out
nicely I don't feel I have to do that I
don't have to stand here and a cappella
sing killing me softly - thanks for the
request um and shake your ass I mean
anytime anyone first Redskins I love the
writing but I originally thought I was
more suited to the character of CID and
that was something that I felt like was
more in my in my repertoire I guess or
something so on when they said they
wanted me to audition to play Tony I was
kind of like okay that's not the
character that reading the script on
instantly gravitates what I think I was
right for I mean the thing that's great
about is you get to play different
characters and try different genres and
different storytelling and all these
things and then that's certainly why try
and do with each need to move your
production or characters I play but I'm
particularly at that time I think I'm
growing up being a child actor to kind
of
I mean I was only 16 at the time so I
still a kid but it's kind of you still
want to appear to be older and that was
quite um you know a progressive show at
the time and kind of very different to
all the other team drummers that had
been on up until that point it was
definitely a conscious decision and one
that luckily paid off and because there
was a lot of talented people involved
and it kind of I think spoke to that
generation the people who are creating
skins wanted it to feel authentic and
real and that was you know casting
people who were the right age and that
made you know the cost involved in that
show uh still got some of my best
friends so it's kind of this wonderful
thing that we were experiencing that
point in our lives making the show but
then on screen were kind of the right
had the right kind of dynamics to be to
be pretending to be doing those things
I'm just marvelous sitting on earth
I remember doing my first sex scene on
that show and obviously that's a scary
weird thing it's just art it's Harry
Enfield as well was directing the
British comedian
who was so well known for his work and
and very funny on sets that he made it
kind of easier and more relaxing I guess
[Music]
looking back it was it you know it was
kind of odd but you kind of it's part of
the process of acting and now I've done
plenty of those things and you kind of
just get more and more relaxed and use
doing them and kind of really try and
figure out I think that experience was
very much trying to just get it done
just get it done and then move on to the
next scene and go back to doing the
other acting now it's kind of each time
one of those scenes comes up in a
production I'm like okay well what are
we learning about the characters what
are we trying to say about them by doing
this by showing it single man a single
man who is it it was a fairly fortunate
move on my part there was another actor
involved and then he couldn't continue
the production so so the script got sent
my way and um but I loved the script and
admittedly I didn't really know much
about Tom Ford at that time I wasn't too
savvy on the fashion world so I did a
tape and sent it across and to the
states and then and got a phone call
kind of the following evening or
something saying hey can you jump on a
plane and come meet Tom Ford he's
interested in you for the role and I was
like brilliant obviously I knew Colin
Firth and Julianne Moore and was a big
fan of their work I thought this was an
incredible story to tell so I kind of
wanted to understand what Tom's
motivation was and sitting and speaking
to him he had such a great understanding
of the story and each character involved
and such I mean you sit with him for
five minutes you understand how smart he
is and his attention to detail and how
created he is as a person and that's one
of the the lovely outcomes of that movie
was um building that relationship with
Tom and getting to spend time with him
and then also at the end of the movie
kind of doing the press tour for that
was around the time that his men's line
I think was kind of launching so he gave
us some beautiful bespoke suits and we
got to wear those then kind of makes you
feel incredible to be in them and and
then when we were doing press for the
movie he asked me to be in a campaign
for his eyewear as well so we did that
so yeah a really great partnership and
kind of um that was kind of I guess it
was slight merging of going into the
fashion world for
getting a better understanding of that
and Kenny was that kind of a quite a
mysterious role he was something that
you kind of people could project upon
what their own ideas and feelings were
didn't notice you open your mouth once I
was watching you you let us ramble on
and on then you straighten us out
you never really tell us everything you
know about something well maybe that's
true
I had fake ten and I lights I remember
very well being in hotel in Pasadena and
then Colin and I would get our fake tans
done in the evening and normally have a
cocktail whilst we had had that done and
then and then
[Music]
have to ask the hotel to clean the
sheets because obviously fake tan rubs
off a lot on wet sheets
I mean I grew up watching the cartoon of
x-men when I was a little kid and then
the original movies came out when I was
I don't know I think like 10 ish 9 10 11
around there the opportunity to be a
part of those movies you know I I don't
think superhero movies as such had
suddenly become quite such a ginormous
event tentpole II type thing that they
are now franchise I guess but um but it
was certainly something that I loved the
x-men and was excited to be a part of
him was Matthew Bourne directing as I
loved his work and what the one odd
thing about I remember about the
audition was Matthew Vaughn asked me to
to do a couple of tapes like in an
American accent as kind of as the
character as you kind of saw the
character but then also do a take doing
an impression of Stewie Griffin from
Family Guy that watched a lot of Family
Guy in my teen years growing up sighs
I'm okay I think I've got a pretty good
impression of Stewie Griffin Lander and
so I did like a whole version of the
take as Stewie Griffin and sent it off
so maybe that helped me get the part I
don't know it was just exciting and
again that character was something I
would say okay I haven't really done
prosthetics work before and make heavy
makeup work so I was interested to see
how that would work
and also this jekyll-and-hyde kind of
aspect to this character I mean I loved
the prosthetics at first you know at
first it's hilarious you put on your the
best makeup in the arts in the world of
making you look like this completely
different person in creature and it's
amazing as an actor to have a completely
different face to then try and act from
and physicality as well I got this
muscle suit and everything is different
obviously there's there's difficult
elements to it it's um it was you know I
started started off in the first movie
taking roughly 3-4 hours to go on and
then by the last movie we did it was
only it was down to about two hours to
get on so it sped up a lot the process
of getting it on but it was still kind
of clearly hot and claustrophobic to
work in so that made it tough at times
but overall I've got you know very funny
behind the scenes videos and photos and
I had a great time kind of trying to
inhabit that character with with all
that happening and working with your
really talented makeup I so
yeah it's a good time one body yeah one
bodies was something that I'm
occasionally there's been a few scripts
that I've kind of read or or received
and all ended up being in where I've
just read it and gone but something's
clicked inside of me and that very much
happened with warm bodies where I was
like okay I think I understand exactly
how to do this I found I found the
script very funny when I first read it
and sensitive and I kind of I loved the
idea of trying to bring this zombie to
life and I thought that Jonathan Levine
was such a great director and he'd
written this brilliant script so
spending time with him I was like it's a
challenge it's definitely a challenge
but it's something that and I felt like
as I think knowing nothing I still felt
like I think maybe you can try and pull
this off and so it was just a fun
process of kind of developing these yeah
this this sound I guess this kind of
groaning guttural voice of what our
would be in his zombie form days past
this way myself and Rob Corddry got to
go to one listen zombie school where we
had a Cirque de Soleil kind of movement
coach come in and for a day or two we
would we would run around like these
offices and car parks like pretending to
smell flesh and then would work on our
like zombie different paces of movement
and how we reacted to these things um
that was the most difficult part that
that movie was doing scene for the Rob
because there'd be scenes where we both
be sat on a bar
not saying a thing but just improvise
improvise groaning at each other but
somehow rob corddry managed to make
improvised
groaning the most hilarious thing in the
world and like I'm the worst for
giggling on set I can't help at the
second and the second I start then I'm
like it's like it's it just captures my
my whole being and I'm like just stop
[Music]
x-men come what gained way and they'd
asked me to kind of get muscly and those
sorts of things yeah this was George
Miller talking to him about the
character obviously Knox was um supposed
to be very sick when you first meet him
at the beginning of the movie so he
asked me to lose weight he wanted
obviously then living and also a
post-apocalyptic world where he wanted
me to look yeah sick and malnourished
all those things so that was something
where ya from a couple of months or
however long it was before shoeing I
just run and jump rope and not eat very
much and I think I managed to lose 20
pounds for that film which now if I look
back and see photos I'm like I didn't
notice at the time but if I could look
back and see photos and I'm like wow you
know I was very skinny for that that
film came about with a really brilliant
audition process that was kind of the
first time I didn't really particularly
go to drama school so suddenly were kind
of doing all these acting games inside
of an audition of observation and things
that went on for four hours and walked
out the audition I was I well that's
unlike any other audition I've ever been
in I loved the process of doing it and
so regardless of whether I get the role
or not I'm excited about what that was
and the opportunity to work with George
in that and then yeah there's the script
for that was I guess yes it was like a
300 page comic book almost with very
little dialogue but each frame of the
movie pretty much storyboarded kind of
if you hold them up now against the
movie that's there it's pretty much shot
for shot Georgia kind of planned
everything out exactly as he'd seen it
in his incredible imagination
Nux was he was a lot he was a lot of fun
to play on because he was a puppy dog
and he and he had this great character
rock both have changed throughout the
story and beliefs and and his it's
relationships with the other characters
first like huh
I like this plan we could start again
and also that environment being in the
desert surrounded by all these engines
it all really happening around you just
you know it made quite an electrifying
atmosphere and experience
I would get chills on my arms whenever
I'd hear that kind of give this signal
to start everyone's engines up before we
take off across the desert to start a
take and when you hear like all these v8
and v12 s and bikes and flamethrowers
and everything kind of starting off and
there was a great kind of camaraderie
between every everyone playing all those
war boys as well there would be
screaming and shouting and kind of this
real it was it was kind of a I mean
cult-like energy or something that was
feverish um to those characters you know
so it was just feeding on that I guess I
was a fan of his work growing up I you
know read I got given the Hobbit to read
on the set of about a boy but by Chris
and Paul the directors and and then the
film's came out not long after there and
I was obsessed with the films I played
the card game so it was something that
was really ingrained in me the worlds
that he'd created but reading the script
I realized I knew very little about the
man behind it so I was like this is an
incredible life he lived I'm n story
behind behind these stories really well
if Tolkien is betraying the brother with
a blank I'm going to show you something
it's intimidating playing playing real
people because I mean it's different I
suppose if you're playing someone from
the modern era whoever who's very
well-known and everyone else kind of
seen on TV or whatever it is and and
then you then you kind of have to do an
impression to a degree with with talking
it was kind of one of those where yeah
there's videos of him later in life but
there's there's photos of him money's
younger but there's no recordings or
video so it's kind of one of those where
that gave me a slight sense of of relief
and also talking to other actors about
it they were like they're like don't
worry about doing an impression because
nobody knows what exactly was character
though a person was like in that era so
you think it was Michael Shannon said
when I was doing a film with him he said
something along the lines of you know
he's not trying to impersonate the
person he's kind of playing a ghost of
them and I think that's kind of the
sense I was going for with tolki and it
was it was an essence of just capturing
the man at that that era of his
- what what he was about what meant a
lot to him and that was his passion for
language and his friends and his lonely
nursing his escapism and his um yeah as
imagination so yeah I thought it was a
beautiful script and obviously you know
intimidating to take on playing a real
person particularly someone you were a
fan of but
if rolls if I read scripts I think the
roles are easy to play then they're
probably not interesting and and then
that's not something that I'd want to go
and do because it's not going to push me
famous as I'm getting older in the more
work I do I do love being able to
transform fully through costume and
makeup and it really gives me a sense of
the character but also that world that
I'm stepping into and and kind of frees
me from any semblance of myself inside
my head when I'm doing it so yeah the
costumes for Harley were incredible I'm
working with Sandy and and the first
time trying on lush gave my character
these huge high heels which I've never
really I don't think too much walk
walked in high heels before so that was
something where suddenly it changes how
how you walk and then you're kind of
having to practice kind of gliding
around these heels as opposed to
stomping around and twisted an ankle so
all those things go into it and then the
jewelry and the cane and Nadia Stacy the
hair and makeup designer giving me these
fantastic wigs that you just kind of
have to balance on top of your head and
and it's just all these things that kind
of just gradually build up and add up to
and it becoming becoming a very subtle
small the idea of working with your boss
who you know as such a singular voice in
moviemaking at the moment I think
watching his films you kind of never
quite know the turn they're gonna take
or or how they're gonna make you feel
this guy's he's just a brilliant
filmmaker so kind of handing over to his
process which again was very different
that was that was a two-week audition
process
I mean two-week rehearsal process not
audition and that would have been a long
time to audition
two weeks rehearsal with the rest of the
cast and kind of I would say probably
actually the most similar experience
I've had some at max where we would play
these games to kind of where we would be
dancing and then we'd be doing the
scenes but we'll be doing them whilst we
had to do these physical tasks at the
same time and all this stuff that you
kind of
don't fully understand that what the
outcome or what the process is trying to
achieve at the time but then you see up
from screen you kind of go oh okay wow
this is it's kind of all on a rhythm and
pace an understanding of what this is
what he is creating it's very rare is
that - that you're kind of put into a
room and everyone's like oh now you're
gonna dance now you're gonna do this now
hold hands and get into the biggest
tangle you possibly can and someone's
got to try and free you and all these
things like we're not sure exactly but
it completely takes away your ego and
kind of puts you in this wonderful place
of playfulness and gives you a freedom
to have fun and fail and enjoy it enjoy
the process and the great
it's written by Toni McNamara who wrote
favorite as well so it's very much
similar to that in tone it's kind of
that kind of dramatic comedic twist on a
period drama this is science in joy and
Peter is someone who hears a stream of
consciousness he's you know he's he's an
emperor of Russia in a time where no
one's really saying no to him it's kind
of this microscopic view of the world at
that point I guess where everyone in the
Court is trying to manipulate him for
their benefit and he's kind of stuck in
the middle that doesn't really want to
be a leader it's kind of walking in the
footsteps or the shadow of his father
before him his mum definitely gave him
some psychological scarring signs a
little bit twisted from that and he's
yeah he's he's obnoxious he's Rudy's
sometimes endearing he's a child
basically um but a very very fun
character the player I haven't done a
series since since skin so to get to
play a character over you know 10 hours
is um there's a lot of fun because then
you can really kind of embed yourself in
them kind of get to grips with them
understand them but then completely
reverse and change and evolve them
throughout throughout the process of
that the filming